alors justement bruno avant d'avoir la
vie des autres est-ce que vous avez déjà
reçu des personnalités
oui oui dans votre établissement elles
sont on a un masque dans votre édition
non non non à quand de fait il convient
mais je suis fermé depuis le 14 mars
cette dernière souffre le 28 novembre
l'ouvrir croyais avec 28 devant j'ai
voulu rouvrir parce que moi je suis pas
une boîte de nuit fâche pas un unique
jeu fessenheim a besoin de 3 heures en
bataillon ranger pour me faire fermer de
force n'a pas un petit peu de foot vous
fait très peu de musique le chant
on a des gens des gens connus qui
viennent aux idées des hommes politiques
des prénoms
est ce qu'un gars autour de la table qui
est allé chez vous oui bruno je vais
être franc je vais te fait frette
reprendre la tête
je ne dirais pas qui c'est non alors est
ce qu on se calme et bruno aubry n'est
pas vraiment une personne autour de la
table
vous avez déjà vu de votre établissement
juste c'est une fille ou un garçon non
je peux pas répondre d'accord mais c'est
une fois les ménages et je répondrai pas
vous l'avez vu une fois je répondrai pas
lancer sans rigoler non parce qu'il ya
une histoire de privé c'est à dire que
le libertin ja c'est un état d'esprit à
bien sûr et je pense que monsieur la
salière qui a fait cette remarque
rés
il faut être honnête aujourd'hui c'est
un peu l'hypocrisie sait très bien que
les hommes politiques comme les
présentateurs télé ou les choix et la
balance et voulez vous avez les
présentateurs télé qui sont nus oui oui
je lis pas d'une femme à boucler ça
commence par ces mots je n'ai pas
d'image avaient vu un ouais c'est dans
le val de marne en crue et ça veut dire
qu'ils se déplacent là bas bien loin ce
à côté c'est pas la loire fait bruno
donc vous avez déjà vu donc des
présentateurs télé les philistins des
chanteurs des acteurs et bien sûr et ses
confidences êtes vous confisquer les
portables là bas alors non il nous
arrive une histoire je voulais raconter
c'était sous l'ère sarkozy
monsieur sarkozy nous avons un homme qui
nous a laissés un portable à l'accueil
parce que des fois les parents laissent
les enfants à la maison et il nous
laisse les portables au bar pour qu'on
puisse la hausse et au cas où et donc
n'a rien de calais parents qui sont en
train de faire deux minutes office
[Rires]
je me suis était très sympa une loi
lagarde et moi mon portable très posé et
puis un moment téléphone a sonné on a vu
afficher sur le portable au bar monsieur
le président sarkosy donc on s'est dit
tiens c'est important ça va être
important donc on a été chercher le
monsieur en plein ébats et on lui a dit
que le portable avait sonné et que l'on
pouvait pas dire ce qui était affiché
parce que halo et puis donc voilà il
était certainement qui après on l'a
reconnue donc voilà
ouais et qu'est ce qu'un débat politique
oui adacore a pas parce qu'après il pour
nicolas sarkozy
non mais il ya tout vous savez c'est
ouvert à tout le monde à partir des
majeures le libertinage c'est une forme
balas et un plaisir c'est un loisir
voilà je serai alors pas sur une idée
malsain de libertinage